the Catholic Diocese of Dallas is
defending its response to sex abuse
claims against priests after police
raided several of its properties
officers searched so-called secret
archives yesterday church officials are
accused of impeding an investigation
Nicky batiste shows us the dramatic
developments Nicky good morning John
good morning in January the Catholic
Diocese in Dallas named nearly 300 of
its priests who had been credibly
accused of sex abuse Dallas police and
the FBI say they launched yesterday's
rate because the diocese hid information
about some of those priests from
investigators
I stand confident as a Bishop of the
Diocese of Dallas that we're doing
what's right even though Bishop Edward
Burns says as diocese has fully
cooperated with law enforcement Dallas
Police still sees boxes of evidence from
secret archives at three diocese
locations this investigation began last
August after allegations of child sex
abuse against local priests Edmundo
Perez became public that's when police
now say more victims came forward with
claims against other priests detectives
are investigating at least five
additional allegations of child abuse
against other suspects according to an
affidavit obtained by CBS News police
say they questioned the diocese about
missing details in a priest file from a
2004 abuse case only after that inquiry
did the diocese reveal 51 pages had been
left out which included one victim's
claim of sex abuse the diocese provided
those pages three weeks later the raid
is the second in Texas in just six
months while those names be on the list
in November CBS News began investigating
the houston/galveston archdiocese and
its Cardinal Daniel DiNardo for
allegedly covering up priests abuse I
would prefer to do this
we've been requesting we'd love to sit
down I don't other time you anything you
say to the survivors and victims one
week after our report police raided the
houston/galveston archdiocese as a
survivor
it's it's
following this latest raid Monica Baez
who says she was abused as a toddler in
the 70s by her priest offered hope to
other survivors don't let them win
don't let that perpetrator take your
life over and they will have justice in
one way or another the five priests
accused of child sex abuse in the
affidavit are no longer in active
ministry the Dallas Police Department
told CBS News no arrests were made in
the raid though there is an active
arrest warrant for at mundo Perez but he
is on the run
I have plod the work of these
prosecutors and law enforcement
officials it's incredible you know - and
you're great reporting thinking to keep
you stay on top of this